j'ai fouillé
ah mais oui je suis le fils de bokassa
présent des malades et tous les blancs
qui sont ici on essayait de noircir
montbert dans une affaire patriotes mais
je vais vous dire je suis en france
présentement pour faire mes études de
président de la république je travaille
le soir au noir
notre jeu l'autre jeu j'aimais promenait
dans la rue avec mon père lorsque sud
est sous nos yeux exorbités écart qu a
paru une blonde pulpeuse lazio j'ai dit
à mon père alors on la bouffe tout de
suite dit non au brésil on la ramène à
la maison et on bouffe ta mère et
attends attends attends attends notre
jules dans l'avion en acier qui nous a
menés à roissy charles de gaulle dans
l'avion j'avais une petite faim alors je
demande de la liste de passagers
elle a déjà gagné le douanier gulu me
dites si oui voilà dans le passé oui
c'est le passé pâle et remarqué si la
non moi j'ai dit oui vous rigolez
atteint atteint signe particulier voir
photo dc une photo en noir et blanc la
double je n'avais pas la couleur bon
sexe rose atteint a dit il me dit vous
pourriez enlevez vos lunettes de soleil
quand vous me parlez là puisque nous
sommes pas mais l'une et son mari
attends attends attends projets dans la
rue j'ai rencontré mon ami honoré il
avait dans les bras un énorme tournant
là qu'est ce que tu fous avec ce tonneau
présentement honoré il disait de voir le
médecin
je dis oui mais pourquoi avec le taureau
présentement honoré il dit les médécins
m'a dit de revenir dans six mois avec
mary lee atteint et l'avait aussi
attachée autour du cou à la place du
prix habituel
il avait un énorme suppositoire je dis
que tu vois je suppositoire présentement
au lourd et ils disent les médecins
il m'a dit de suspendre le traitement la
course et nous les africains nous les
noirs
quand nous aurons pris le pouvoir nous
ferons comme c'est marqué dans le grand
livre
nous mettrons tous les blancs dans la
montagne à dakhla les blancs et les
jaunes la plus cotée les rues la plus
cotée s'est marqué dans le grand livre
si tu veux réussir il faut battre les
jaunes et mode et les blancs en neige